our houses are a really strange place
for these tiny apex predators to live
24/7 a lot of cats are just hopelessly
bored felines in general don't do well
with confinement cats and zoos exercise
a lot of weird pacing behaviors a lot of
the stuff we see cats do you know could
be just because they don't have enough
activities at for enrichment inside of
the house I think that box behaviors
though are really interesting the
classic example is the Japanese cat Maru
that we see hopping into boxes and
outside of boxes and and I think that
what we see in Maru and cats hopping in
and out of boxes is a kind of classic
feline hunting behavior this is an
ambush performance that we're seeing
nature cats don't chase after their prey
like you see animals like wolves and
other types of canines do they are very
hidden sudden explosive predators cats
like to be inside of boxes because these
are sort of secretive cryptic hiding
spots where they can lie and wait and
watch the world you see the cats they
explode out of there they're hiding
spots very suddenly and this makes for
great little video clips but really it's
just a very typical feline hunting
behavior one of the interesting twists
though is that we never would have seen
these really cool athletic things that
cats can do up until about 50 years ago
when cats are becoming more sort of a
normal domestic presence and a standard
household pet but cats outside we now
get the opportunity to see them do
they're very impressive hunting feats as
much we have to recognize that this is
sort of a rare privilege that we have
today to have these little guys trapped
inside of our houses with us so we can
see all the cool stuff that they just do
as a matter of routine like explosively
hop out of different hiding spots
[Music]